What If instead of having to pay money
for a
smartphone what if you could get paid to
use your phone well that is what a
company called M mobile is doing they
created a phone that you can buy right
now at places like Best Buy in Walmart
that will actually pay you for simple
things like unlocking your phone
charging your phone shopping banking
installing apps and it actually works
they paid out over $150 million in
rewards to users and users earn an
average of $3 to $40 a month and since
the phone is only around $100 users can
make back their money in just a few
months take installing an app for
example if an app knows that they can
make say $2 off of every download they
can partner with mo mobile and pay them
$1 for every install that is how they're
able to make this work mold mobile is
the paid sponsor of this video
disclaimer and disclosures are on the
screen now and they're actually doing a
public friend race so if you want to
invest in them go to the link on the
screen now don't invest more money than
you can lose